the Republican primary field is very
quickly getting much more crowded
including with two very interesting new
entrants Mike Pence expected to announce
he will run against his own former
president under whom he served and Chris
Christie is going to announce that he is
entering this race which is very very
interesting for other reasons which I
will talk about in a moment we will
start with Mike Pence Mike Pence reports
NPR expected to announce 2024 run for
president on on June 7th at an event in
Des Moines according to a source
familiar with the campaign I am sure
that it will be an electric atmosphere
when Mike Pence makes this announcement
no it won't uh it will be quite the
opposite but it will be an interesting
announcement nonetheless and we'll talk
about why in a moment NPR writes Pence
has been signaling his plans for several
months with several stops in early
voting States like New Hampshire and
Iowa
and the announcement of a Super PAC
supporting his bid Pence will join at
least nine other Republicans attempting
to unseat Trump as the front-runner for
the Republican nomination now what will
Pence's campaign look like because if
you serve as vice president to Trump and
then you run against him you can't do
the thing that Nikki Haley and Tim Scott
and others are doing where you don't
criticize Trump right if you're saying I
disagree so much with the guy I served
under that I will run against him you
have to explain what your disagreements
are I think NPR writes in the past
several weeks Pence has previewed a
campaign focused on returning the
Republican party to traditional
Republican themes like expanding free
markets fiscal responsibilities
supporting American Allies abroad and
small government he has made more
pointed attacks on Trump his former
running mate by invoking his own Faith
and family values and promising to
respect to respect the Constitution here
is an MSNBC NBC news report of the
moment when news of this broke
[Music]
we have breaking news regarding a new
entry into the already crowded
Republican race for President we told
you last hour that on Tuesday Chris
Christie was getting in now on Wednesday
former vice president Mike Pence NBC's
John Allen has the very latest he's
breaking the story and joins me on the
phone John what can you tell us
uh I can tell you Mike Pence is in uh as
of a week from today he will be doing a
video uh probably in the morning and
then a launch speech in Des Moines Iowa
it is very focused on uh Iowa as are a
lot of campaigns as a place that they
believe is very hospitable to the former
Vice President part because of its uh
strong Evangelical Republican base so
he'll be doing that speech uh sometime
on uh on the seventh and then uh there's
going to be a town hall later that night
okay so that is the CNN Town Hall last
week we we thought that Pence was going
in this direction because we knew CNN
had scheduled a republican town hall
with Pence and we said to ourselves
would they be doing that if this guy was
not going in the direction of running so
currently currently Mike Pence is
running in fourth place we have the
latest polling here as you can see the
big purple line at the top is Trump at
53 the green line sort of in the middle
of this screen is DeSantis at 22 so
Trump 53 DeSantis 22 then it's Nikki
Haley at about four and a half percent
and after Nikki Haley is Mike Pence at
3.8 percent just ahead of Vivek
ramaswamy will the announcement get some
new support for Mike Pence it might a
couple of points worth I would I would
expect but is this going to be a big
shake-up to the Republican primary I
don't think so and part of it has to do
with the fact that many of the very
people
who are not on the Maga side
don't see Penn says the strongest
alternative partially because Pence even
though he may be displeased with some of
the way that Donald Trump managed the
presidency or whatever Pence is too
close if you want to go anti-maga you
probably don't go with the Maga vice
president as much distance as Pence
would like to put between himself and
Trump so the question is going to be
for the Maga group
is there an alternative to Trump I doubt
it would be Pence because many of those
Maga people are mad that Pence quote
didn't send it back to the states in uh
in in 2020
um to try to prevent Joe Biden from
becoming president in 2020 and 2021 even
though he really couldn't do that and so
it's unlikely that they would say well
we really are Maga we want something
better so we'll go with Pence because
they see Pence as an enemy quite frankly
thanks to the rhetoric from Donald Trump
on the other hand the anti-maga people
would likely go with someone who was
never affiliated with Donald Trump so I
don't exactly see how Mike Pence is
going to get anything out of this Mike
Pence is I believe in his early in his
early 60s 60s Mike Pence age a 63 so I
don't know if Pence is calculating that
if he wants to do this he'd rather do it
at age 63 rather than 67 and maybe
closer to when he is more of a household
name maybe fit Thinking by 2028 maybe
people will have forgotten about me I
don't know again I don't exactly know
what Pence is thinking I see the
campaign is Dead on Arrival but let's
now talk about a much more interesting
campaign than that of Mike Pence let's
talk about Chris Christie if you've been
getting crushed in the markets lately
like many people have you were probably
happy to hear that treasury yields have
been surging right now you can get a
five percent yield on treasury bills
Which is higher than most high-yield
savings accounts I've seen and unlike a
high-yield savings account treasury
bills are a fixed rate asset so you know
what you're getting at the time of
purchase but buying U.S treasuries can
be very complicated or at least it was
because our sponsor public.com mom lets
you buy treasury bills in seconds right
from your phone and put your cash to
work keep in mind that treasury bills
are government-backed securities
considered one of the safest Investments
around when you buy them on public they
are securely stored at the Bank of New
York Mellon the world's largest
custodian bank and Security Services
Company plus there are no minimum hold
periods or settlement delays you can
access funds anytime if you keep it
invested public will automatically roll
over your Investments at maturity so you
have one thing you don't have to think
about go to public.com Pacman to start
getting that five percent yield on your
cash the link is down below